One of the first times I met David Rakoff-- this is before he started writing stories for the radio-- he invited me to sit in the window of a department store with him. He was playing Sigmund Freud in a Christmas display window at Barney's, and he was seeing patients in the window. David sat in a chair. I lay on a couch.
我第一次见到大卫·拉科夫（David Rakoff）的情景之一——那是在他开始为广播写故事之前——他邀请我和他一起坐在百货商店的橱窗里。当时他在巴尼斯百货（Barney's）的圣诞陈列橱窗里扮演西格蒙德·弗洛伊德（Sigmund Freud），并在橱窗里为病人看诊。大卫坐在椅子上，我躺在沙发上。
My mom was the therapist. David's dad was a psychiatrist. We'd both been therapy patients ourselves at some point or another. And so it was easy for us to play this simulacrum of psychiatry with each other. I don't remember what we talked about. It was so long ago. But I remember very clearly the feeling of it.
我妈妈是心理治疗师，大卫的父亲是精神科医生。我们俩在某个时期都曾是心理治疗的患者，所以我们很容易就能彼此扮演这种心理治疗的模拟游戏。我不记得我们聊了些什么，那已经是太久以前的事了，但我清楚地记得当时的感受。
David, gently asking leading general questions like a real therapist would-- how are things going? Why do you think you said that? It was easy to talk to him. And unlike the real Sigmund Freud, he offered advice. And it was surprisingly cozy.
大卫温柔地提出一些引导性的常规问题，就像真正的治疗师那样——最近怎么样？你为什么觉得你会那么说？和他聊天很轻松，而且与真正的西格蒙德·弗洛伊德不同，他还会给出建议。那种感觉出奇地舒适。
Though one wall of the room that we were in was this plate glass window that faced Madison Avenue, the space was narrow and cocoon-like. The muffled street noise that leaked through the window made it feel more womb-like if anything. People on the street couldn't hear what we said to each other. So it was both public and intimate. I left feeling close to him. I left wishing we could do it again.
尽管我们所在的房间有一面墙是面对麦迪逊大道的落地窗，但空间狭窄且像个蚕茧。透过窗户渗进来的闷响街声，反而让这里感觉更像子宫。街上的人听不见我们的对话，所以这里既公开又私密。我离开时感觉和他亲近了许多，也希望我们能再做一次。
And we did, in a way. Nearly everything he ever made for our radio show was a personal act, made in close collaboration for public consumption, performed behind a plate glass window of one kind or another. This week marks the fifth anniversary of his death. He'd been on This American Life 25 times. The first time was in 1996, just two months after we went on the air. The last was just three weeks before he died.
在某种程度上，我们确实做到了。他为我们的广播节目制作的几乎每一件作品都是个人的行为，在密切合作下为了公共消费而创作，在某种玻璃橱窗后进行表演。本周是他逝世五周年纪念日。他曾上过《美国生活》（This American Life）节目25次。第一次是在1996年，就在我们开播两个月后；最后一次是在他去世前三周。
He travelled with the show when we took it on the road and on tour. When the staff and some favorite contributors all had our testosterone levels tested as a stunt for an episode in 2002, David, to everybody's surprise including his, was the one with the highest testosterone. When my mom died in 2003, and for the first time we had a guest host fill in for me, David was the guest host. Because of that, I have a recording of him handling this next bit of business I need to do.
我们巡回演出时，他也会随行。2002年为了节目特辑，我们测试了员工和几位心仪撰稿人的睾酮水平，结果令所有人（包括大卫自己）惊讶的是，大卫的睾酮水平最高。2003年我母亲去世，我们第一次请客座主持人代班，大卫就是那位客座主持人。正因如此，我保留了一段他处理接下来我要做的这件琐事的录音。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm David Rakoff. Stay with us, won't you?
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是大卫·拉科夫。请留下来听，好吗？
Today, those of us who make this radio show have the pleasure of bringing you an hour of stories by our friend, David Rakoff. This is the show we made and broadcast back when he died to remember him by. David helped invent and define what our radio show is. And he was just a great writer-- lucid and funny and mean and big-hearted.
今天，我们这些制作这个广播节目的人有幸为大家带来一小时由我们的朋友大卫·拉科夫创作的故事。这是他在去世时我们为了纪念他而制作并播出的节目。大卫帮助发明并定义了我们的广播节目是什么。他是一位伟大的作家——思路清晰、风趣幽默、刻薄犀利且胸怀宽广。
He was that way in conversation, too. In thinking about what stories to put on today's program, I realized that David has been on the program so often that we have stories covering most of the different phases in his life. We could actually line up the essays in an order and tell his life story. And we're going to do that, at least for a bit here.
他在交谈中也是如此。在思考今天节目要放哪些故事时，我意识到大卫上节目的频率非常高，以至于我们有涵盖他人生不同阶段的故事。我们甚至可以按顺序排列这些文章，讲述他的人生故事。我们打算这么做，至少在这里讲一部分。
As you'll hear, it is not a story with big dramatic turns and surprises. But like the old saying goes, great stories happen to those who can tell them. These are very, very fun to listen to.
正如你将听到的，这不是一个充满戏剧性转折和惊喜的故事。但正如那句老话所说，伟大的故事只会发生在那些能讲述它们的人身上。这些故事听起来非常有意思。
So, David was born in Canada. He talked about Canada and his Canadianness with me in an interview back in 1997, the third time he appeared on our radio program. He said that, actually, from the day that he arrived in New York City for college as a teenager, he didn't want to seem Canadian. He wanted to pass as a New Yorker.
大卫出生在加拿大。1997年他在我们广播节目第三次露面时，曾接受采访谈论加拿大及他的加拿大身份。他说，实际上，从他十几岁到纽约上大学那天起，他就不想显得像个加拿大人，他想假装成纽约人。
My tactics were to adopt a certain kind of world-weary, jaded, anxious neuroticism. And it was taken on as a cosmetic mantle at the beginning until such time as, you know, you simply can't pull the mask off your face. Oh my god, it's stuck! But there you are, years later, a jaded, affectless, neurotic, disenchanted, sad person.
我的策略是采取一种愤世嫉俗、厌世、焦虑且神经质的态度。起初这只是作为一种外表的伪装，直到你最终无法再摘下那张面具。天哪，它粘住了！但几年后，你就会变成一个愤世嫉俗、无动于衷、神经质、心灰意冷且忧郁的人。
I'm told that Canadians tend to know who else is Canadian, you know, who's famous.
听说加拿大人往往能一眼认出谁也是加拿大人，你知道的，比如名人。
All the time, everything. And that, to me, is chemical. You know, there are the easy ones, you know, Kate Nelligan, Hume Cronyn, Cowboy Junkies, Monty Hall.
一直都能认出来，所有人都行。对我来说，这是一种化学反应。你知道，有一些容易认出的，比如凯特·内利根（Kate Nelligan）、休姆·克罗宁（Hume Cronyn）、牛仔垃圾乐队（Cowboy Junkies）、蒙蒂·霍尔（Monty Hall）。
Monty Hall? Wait, Monty Hall?
蒙蒂·霍尔？等等，蒙蒂·霍尔？
Monty Hall.
蒙蒂·霍尔。
The host of Let's Make a Deal?
《让我们做个交易》（Let's Make a Deal）的主持人？
Yeah. Live and learn, huh?
对。活到老学到老，是吧？
Who could be more American than the host of Let's Make a Deal? Even the name, Let's Make a Deal.
还有谁能比《让我们做个交易》的主持人更像美国人？连那个名字《让我们做个交易》都充满了美国味。
And yet, remember Monty only facilitated the deals.
然而，记住，蒙蒂只是在促成交易而已。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Who else?
还有谁？
Glenn Ford, John Kenneth Galbraith. But here's the thing about knowing who's Canadian. I mean, there is a woman named Shania Twain. She is Canadian. I know that she's Canadian. I do not know who the hell Shania Twain is. I don't know what she does. And yet, for some reason, I know that she's famous in America and that she's Canadian.
格伦·福特（Glenn Ford）、约翰·肯尼斯·加尔布雷斯（John Kenneth Galbraith）。但了解谁是加拿大人这点很特别。我的意思是，有个叫仙妮亚·唐恩（Shania Twain）的女性，她是加拿大人。我知道她是加拿大人，但我根本不知道仙妮亚·唐恩是谁。我不知道她是干什么的，但出于某种原因，我知道她在美国家喻户晓，而且她是加拿大人。
How did this come up? Did your parents talk to you about it?
这事是怎么提出来的？你父母跟你谈过吗？
I literally don't know. I feel there's a chip in my head. How do these things enter my brain?
我真的不知道。我觉得我脑子里有个芯片。这些事情是怎么进入我大脑的？
But at some point, somebody told you?
但在某个时候，有人告诉过你？
I don't even think so, you know? I just think it comes in off the breeze or on a cold front. And I know. I just know in my heart who's Canadian. It's so strange. And of course, you know, the arm on your space shuttle--
我不这么认为。我觉得这就像随风或寒流飘进来的信息。我就是知道，我内心深处知道谁是加拿大人。这太奇怪了。当然，还有你那太空梭上的机械臂——
I'm sorry?
抱歉？
The arm on your space shuttle, for making interstellar repairs.
你太空梭上的那个用来进行星际维修的机械臂。
In Canada, the space shuttle was referred to as--
在加拿大，太空梭被称为——
The American space shuttle with its Canadian-built arm.
美国太空梭配有加拿大制造的机械臂。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Never any other way, as in the American space shuttle with its Canadian-built arm blew up today.
从没听过别的叫法，比如“今天，美国太空梭配有加拿大制造的机械臂坠毁了”。
No, that didn't really happen.
不，那不是真的发生了。
No, well, I was actually here at the time, but the Canadian-built arm gets a lot of air play. Not down here, huh? In fact, if you were to ask most Canadians, what do you think the space shuttle is for, they'd say, oh, you know, to go up and move stuff around in space-- with an arm.
不，好吧，我当时确实在这里，但加拿大制造的机械臂确实得到了很多宣传。在这边没有，对吧？事实上，如果你问大多数加拿大人太空梭是干什么用的，他们会说，哦，你知道，就是上去在太空中移动东西——用机械臂。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
You know.
你知道的。
And so when a Canadian finds out that some figure is Canadian, what happens in their heart?
所以当加拿大人发现某个人是加拿大人时，他们心里会发生什么？
Oh, well, your heart does a little bit of-- a certain special Canadians chamber opens up and enfolds that name, and you keep it. Or if you mention a Canadian, a famous Canadian, in conversation to a Canadian without acknowledging it, there's a vague flicker over their eyes like the shadow of an angel's wing passing. And then the conversation will go on and on, and then just as an after thought they'll say, oh, you know, he's Canadian, by the way. You know, of course it's all you've been waiting to say the entire conversation.
哦，你的心会产生一点点反应——一个特别的“加拿大空间”被打开并包容了那个名字，你就记住了。或者，如果你在与加拿大人交谈时提到某位著名的加拿大人却没承认这一点，他们的眼神会掠过一丝模糊的闪烁，就像天使翅膀的阴影掠过。然后谈话会继续进行，接着在最后他们会随口说，哦，顺便说一下，他是加拿大人。你知道的，这当然是你整个谈话中唯一想说的话。
You would actually say at some point, you know he's Canadian?
你真的会在某个时候说，“你知道他是加拿大人吗？”
I wouldn't even-- not even at some point, Ira. Let's try it. Go on. You start.
我甚至不会——甚至不会等到某个时候，艾拉（Ira）。我们试一下，来吧，你开始。
All right. So anyway, I was in the car on my way to work. And that song from Bachman-Turner Overdrive--
好吧。所以，总之，我开车去上班的时候。然后巴赫曼-特纳超速乐队（Bachman-Turner Overdrive）的那首歌——
They're Canadian.
他们是加拿大人。
--came on.
——播了出来。
That's how I do it. I don't even wait. I don't even wait.
我就是这样做的。我甚至不用等，我根本不用等。
There are other bits of his childhood that David wrote about over the years. In 1998 on our program, he talked about this incident from high school that was a big turning point for him. At the time, he was part of a Zionist socialist group in Toronto, very idealistic about Israel. They would meet every week and at 15, go live on a collective farm, a kibbutz, in Israel for the summer.
大卫多年来还写过其他关于童年的琐事。1998年，他在我们的节目中谈到了高中时期发生的一件事，那对他来说是一个重大的转折点。当时他是多伦多一个锡安主义社会主义团体的成员，对以色列非常理想化。他们每周聚会，还在15岁时去以色列的一个集体农场（基布兹）度过夏天。
There we would meet other members of the movement from all over the world and spend many a happy hour engaged in honest labor, sing Crosby, Stills, Nash, and Young songs, and if one's older siblings were any indication, lose our virginity.
在那里，我们会结识来自世界各地的运动成员，度过许多快乐时光，从事诚实的劳动，唱着Crosby, Stills, Nash and Young乐队的歌，如果年长的同伴们有什么前兆可循的话，还会失去我们的童贞。
From the start, David did not do well working in the fields. He suffered heat stroke. And then one day came, David recalled, the boys were informed that they would be doing a special work detail that night that was going to begin at midnight and that no girls would be accompanying them. It was going to be men's work, men only. So after 11:00 they gathered, and they were driven to the farm's chicken house.
一开始，大卫在田里干活表现并不好。他中暑了。后来有一天，大卫回忆说，男生们被告知那天晚上要执行一项特殊的任务，从午夜开始，没有女生陪同。那是男人的活，只限男人。所以11点过后他们集合，被开车送到了农场的鸡舍。
The chicken coup of the kibbutz was a one-storied structure of corrugated iron, about half the size of a football field. It emitted a low rumbling, a vague buzz that you could hear from far away. And of course, from even farther away, there was the smell. Chicken [BLEEP] is an olfactory insult, a snarling saw-toothed ammoniac cheesy smell, needlessly gratuitously disgusting.
基布兹的养鸡场是一个铁皮波纹顶的单层结构，大约半个足球场大。它发出一种低沉的隆隆声，一种从远处就能听到的模糊嗡嗡声。当然，更远的地方还能闻到那种气味。鸡粪是一种嗅觉上的侮辱，一种咆哮的、锯齿状的、像氨水和奶酪混合的味道，无谓且毫无理由地令人作呕。
Rather than making you never want to eat a chicken again, it simply makes you angry. It makes you hold a grudge. You'll eat chicken again, by god, and you'll chew really, really hard.
与其让你以后再也不想吃鸡肉，它只会让你感到愤怒。它让你心怀怨恨。你还是会吃鸡肉，该死的，而且你会嚼得非常非常用力。
One of the barrel-chested Israelis shows us what to do. Pick up four chickens in each hand. This is done by grabbing hold of the birds by one leg. "If the leg snaps," he says, "it doesn't matter. Just to get four in each hand. So there." he says. "OK?"
其中一个胸膛宽阔的以色列人向我们展示怎么做。每只手抓四只鸡。这通过抓住鸟的一条腿来实现。“如果腿折了，”他说，“没关系。只要每只手抓四只。就像这样。”他说，“明白吗？”
He faces us, holding the requisite eight, four in each hand, living messes of writhing feathers. He looks like some German expressionist cheerleader, his pompoms alive, convulsing, filthy. "Who will see their dreams fall away into the abyss and eventually succumb to the crushing sadness and meaninglessness of it all? We will. And what does that spell? Madness! Louder! I can't hear you!"
他面对我们，手里拿着所需的八只，每只手四只，那一团团乱扭的羽毛活物。他看起来像个德国表现主义啦啦队长，手里的绒球活蹦乱跳、抽搐、肮脏不堪。“谁会眼睁睁看着自己的梦想坠入深渊，最终屈服于那种毁灭性的悲伤和毫无意义？我们会。那拼写出来是什么？疯狂！大声点！我听不见你们！”
He crams the chickens roughly into a blue plastic crate, smeared with wet guano. "And you close the lid, and chick-chuck," he tells us, clapping his hands with "that's that" finality.
他粗暴地把鸡塞进一个沾满湿鸟粪的蓝色塑料板条箱里。“然后你关上盖子，咯哒——搞定，”他告诉我们，拍着手表现出“就是这样”的决绝。
Before I even try, I know that I will not be able to do this. It is midnight, and we will be here until dawn or until the truck is piled to capacity with crated birds. I walk out into the sea of chickens. I reached down and grab one, its leg a slightly thicker segmented chopstick. I recoil and stand up. I take a fetid breath, regroup, and bend down with new resolve, grab the chicken by its body with both hands, thinking, somehow, that might be preferable. Although, how I think I'm going to get eight of them this way, I'm not sure. Its ribs expand and contract under my fingers, a dirty, warm, live umbrella. I drop the bird as if it were boiling hot.
在我尝试之前，我就知道我做不到。现在是午夜，我们要在这里一直待到天亮，或者直到卡车装满板条箱。我走进鸡群的海洋。我弯腰抓起一只，它的腿就像一根稍粗的分节筷子。我退缩着站起来。我吸了一口恶臭的空气，重新振作，带着新的决心弯下腰，用双手抓住鸡的身体，不知怎么想的，觉得那样可能会好点。尽管我不知道怎么用这种方式抓八只。它的肋骨在我的手指下起伏，一个肮脏、温暖、活生生的雨伞。我像丢掉滚烫的东西一样扔掉了那只鸟。
I leave the coop and go out to the trucks. Hoisting myself up onto the flat bed, I start to help with the stacking of the full crates. I know that my unilateral decision to change my task is met with displeasure on the part of the men who run the coop, but I do not care. Their muttered comments are predicated on a direct poultry-penile relationship. I might as well have spurned the stag party whore or gone to the wood shop and fashion myself a sign that said "fag."
我离开鸡舍走到卡车旁。爬上平板卡车，开始帮忙堆放装满的板条箱。我知道我单方面改变任务的决定引起了管理鸡舍男人们的不满，但我不在乎。他们嘀咕的评论基于一种直接的家禽与生殖器的联系。我还不如干脆拒绝那些单身派对上的妓女，或者去木工间给自己做个写着“同性恋”的牌子。
"[INAUDIBLE], what's the matter with him?" the head of the work detail asks when he sees me on the truck. [SPEAKING HEBREW], he is answered, using the female pronoun when referring to me. "The lady doesn't like the chickens."
“那个谁，他怎么了？”当我出现在卡车上时，领队问道。（希伯来语说话），有人回答他，用阴性代词来指代我。“那位女士不喜欢鸡。”
It would be years before I was referred to as "she" again, and then very rarely and only as a joke by friends. I turn around to look at the men, making it quite clear to them that I understand what they're saying. The man who called me "she" avoids my eyes and busies himself was straightening a pile of crates and tightening the tarpaulin on the side of the truck. "You're right," I tell him in Hebrew, "she doesn't like the chickens."
那是多年来我第一次再被当作“她”来称呼，而且在那之后非常罕见，通常只是朋友间的玩笑。我转过身看着那些男人，清楚地让他们知道我明白他们在说什么。那个叫我“她”的男人避开我的目光，忙着整理一堆板条箱，拉紧卡车侧面的防水布。“你说得对，”我用希伯来语告诉他，“她不喜欢鸡。”
Have you ever had one of those moments when you know that you're being visited by your own future? They come so rarely and with so little fanfare, those moments. They're not particularly photogenic. There no breach in the clouds to reveal the shining city on a hill-- no folk dancing children outside your bus, no production values to speak of, just a glimpse of such quotidian incontrovertible truth that, after the initial shock at the supreme weirdness of it all, a kind of calm sets in. So this is to be my life?
你有过那种时刻吗，知道自己被未来拜访了？这些时刻来得太少，且几乎没有预兆。它们不是特别上镜。云层没有裂开显露出山巅之城——车窗外没有跳民间舞的孩子，没有任何值得一提的艺术修养，只是瞥见了某种日常且无可辩驳的真相，在对这一切极其怪异的最初震惊之后，一种平静油然而生。这就是我将要度过的一生吗？
At that very moment, I saw that I would never live on a kibbutz. I would not lose my virginity that summer to any of the girls from the group. Indeed, I would not care to do so. I am grateful to that macho blowhard. He made me consciously realize what I had always known but been somehow unable to say to myself. He's right. I don't like chickens. I like men.
就在那一刻，我明白我永远不会住在基布兹。那个夏天我也不会失去童贞给群体里的任何女孩。事实上，我也根本没兴趣。我很感激那个大男子主义的吹牛大王。他让我清醒地意识到了我一直知道、却不知为何无法对自己说出口的事。他是对的。我不喜欢鸡。我喜欢男人。
Now I live in Manhattan, the un-kibbutz, where nobody would dream of touching a live chicken, where whatever spirit of collectivist altruism people might have had dried up long ago. At camp when I was young, I and the other children of affluent professionals would gather under the trees every day to sing before going into lunch. One of the songs was always "The Internationale," the hymn of the proletariat.
现在我住在曼哈顿，这个“非基布兹”的地方，没人会梦想去触碰活鸡，这里人们可能有的任何集体主义利他精神早已枯竭。小时候在夏令营，我和其他富裕专业人士的子女每天午饭前都会聚集在树下唱歌。其中一首歌总是《国际歌》，无产阶级的圣歌。
One summer, we were even taught to sing it with our left fists raised. We were none of us, by any stretch of the imagination, what could be described as prisoners of starvation, wretched of the earth or enthralled slaves. Admittedly, they are all catchier metaphors and easier to scan than "arise, you children of psychiatrists." But they had little to nothing to do with us personally.
有一个夏天，我们甚至被教导要举起左拳歌唱。我们中间没有任何人能被想象成所谓的“饥饿的囚徒”、“受苦的人”或“被奴役的奴隶”。诚然，这些比“起来，精神科医生的孩子们”更容易押韵和节奏感更好。但它们与我们个人几乎毫无关系。
And yet, for those few moments when we were singing, those words seemed so true. How can I describe to you that 11-year-old's sense of purpose? That thrill of belonging to something larger, something outside of my own body? The sheer heart-stopping beauty of a world of justice and perfection arising on new foundations?
然而，在那唱歌的几分钟里，那些词听起来是那么真实。我该如何向你描述那个11岁孩子的目标感？那种属于某种更宏大的事物、某种自身身体之外的事物的快感？那种世界在新的基础上建立正义与完美的惊心动魄的美？
And that one line-- "We have been naught. We shall be all." Naught-- it spoke as much about my wish to be delivered from this pre-adolescent self-loathing as it did to any consciousness of liberating the masses. But it held such promise of what I might hope for that even now as I write this, I can still call up that old fervor. It still makes my breath catch in my throat.
还有那一句——“我们一无所有，我们要做一切。”“无”——它既诉说了我渴望从这种青春期前的自我厌恶中解脱出来的愿望，也诉说了那种解放大众的意识。但它充满了希望，以至于即使现在写到这里，我仍然能唤起那种旧日的热忱。它依然让我的喉咙哽咽。
You're listening to This American Life. We're hearing stories by David Rakoff. So, David goes to college at 17. He has an incredible ear for mimicry. He has a real gift for languages. He majors in Japanese at school. He told me once that was because it was the hardest language he could find. After graduating, he moves to Japan. He moves to Japan, gets a job. It's 1986. And in this office job, David was convinced that he understood something about their business in this office that no one else in the office could see.
你正在收听《美国生活》。我们正在听大卫·拉科夫的故事。所以，大卫17岁上大学。他有惊人的模仿天赋。他非常有语言天赋，在学校主修日语。他曾告诉我，那是因为那是他能找到的最难的语言。毕业后，他搬到了日本。那是1986年，他在一份办公室工作中，确信自己看出了办公室业务中没人能看出的东西。
Primarily the office was an advertising agency. But what they were setting up was this thing for expatriates who were living in Tokyo at the time or perhaps all of Japan. And it was like a network on a computer. And they would set up a newsletter on the network. And people could, quote, "log on to the computer and talk to one another or do research." And I was just-- I don't know. I just looked around the room, and I saw these computers and could only think, like, what kind of loser would log onto a computer, talk to someone.
那家办公室主要是一家广告代理公司。但他们当时正在为生活在东京或许是全日本的外籍人士设置一套东西，就像电脑上的一个网络。他们会在网上设置一个新闻简报，人们可以“登录电脑互相交流或做研究”。而我只是——我不知道。我看着房间四周，看到这些电脑，心想，什么样的人会登录电脑去和别人说话？
And in fact, that night in my diary, I had written something like, this is like those comic book enthusiasts who actually read the little instructions at the bottom of the panel that said, you know, "for more on the Green Goblin, check out Spidey number 137," you know, from the editor.
事实上，那天晚上我在日记里写道，这就像那些漫画书爱好者，他们真的会读面板底部那些小说明，比如“想了解更多绿恶魔的信息，请查看《蜘蛛侠》第137期”之类的，来自编辑的留言。
And in almost the only moment of decisiveness in my entire adult life-- I've certainly never equaled this-- I went in the next morning, and I quit. And all I could think was like, sayonara, suckers! You know, good luck with your network. And we know exactly what the network was. It was the internet.
在我成年生活中几乎唯一一个果断的时刻——我肯定从未超越过这一点——我第二天早上就去辞职了。我当时想的只是：再见，傻瓜们！祝你们的网络好运。而我们都知道那网络到底是什么。那是互联网。
I have a negative capacity to identify trends. Like, when in college I went to see Madonna, at Danceteria, which was a club downtown, like 1982 or whatever. And I thought, boy is she lousy!
我识别趋势的能力是负数的。就像大学时我去丹塞特瑞亚（Danceteria）俱乐部看麦当娜（Madonna）的演出，那是1982年左右。我想，天哪，她太烂了！
Are there examples besides Madonna and the internet?
除了麦当娜和互联网，还有其他例子吗？
Other than Madonna and the internet, you need another example? When I was an editorial assistant working in publishing, I was handed a manuscript to read. I think I wrote something like "subliterate, borderline misogyny, an easy pass." And somebody thought, I'm just going to take a look at this anyway. It was Men Are From Mars, Women Are From Venus.
除了麦当娜和互联网，你还需要别的例子吗？我还在出版社做编辑助理时，有人递给我一份手稿让我读。我想我当时写的是“文学功底低下，有厌女症倾向，轻易否决”。而有人想，我还是看一下吧。那是《男人来自火星，女人来自金星》。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
These are not like me saying like, I don't think Alicia Silverstone is going to be very good in Clueless. I mean, these are like, you know--
这些不像我说什么“我觉得艾丽西亚·希尔维斯通（Alicia Silverstone）在《独领风骚》（Clueless）里不会演得很好”。我是说，这些都是——
Pretty big, iconic ones.
相当大的标志性事件。
Yeah. It was like, have you fellas heard that crazy lunatic in the marketplace inveighing against the Pharisees? He'll burn off like so much morning fog. We'll never hear about him ever-- you know, it's just like that.
是的。这就好比，那些在市场上大声谴责法利赛人的疯子，你们听说了吗？他很快就会像晨雾一样消失，我们永远不会再听到他的消息了——你知道，就是那样。
So David's living in Japan. And he's only there for two or three months in this new life that he's made for himself when he gets cancer for the first time. Hodgkin's lymphoma, he's 22. He flies home to Canada for treatment, radiation, then chemo, takes over a year before he'll be well again.
所以大卫住在日本。在他为自己开创的新生活中才待了两三个月，他就第一次患上了癌症。霍奇金淋巴瘤，他才22岁。他飞回加拿大接受治疗、放疗，然后化疗，花了一年多时间才康复。
There's a story that David wrote years ago. And just a few days after he died, I listened back to it. I hadn't heard it since the year 2000 when we first broadcast it. David was 35 when this aired. In the story, he was looking back on this first experience that he had with cancer, back in his 20s. He was treated at Princess Margaret Hospital in Toronto.
大卫多年前写过一个故事。在他去世后几天，我回听了那个故事。自2000年我们首次播出以来，我就再没听过。大卫播出时才35岁。在这个故事中，他回顾了自己20多岁时第一次患癌症的经历。他在多伦多的玛格丽特公主医院接受治疗。
And there's this scene in the story where he describes what it was like to go there and get treatment.
故事里有这样一个场景，他描述了去那里接受治疗的感觉。
The radiation room itself is a lead-lined interior chamber of the hospital. Two red laser beams cross over the exact center of the table where the patients lie. Using the cross of four small black tattoos on my torso, the technicians line me up and ready me for the thousands of rads of radiation.
放疗室本身是医院内部一个铅衬的房间。两束红色激光交叉在患者躺的台子的正中心。利用我躯干上四个小黑刺青构成的十字，技术员将我排好位，准备接受数千拉德（rads）的辐射。
The machine is bulbous, huge, and a dull hospital green, a death ray straight out of '50s sci-fi. I lie down and look up. Above my head, directly at eye level, someone has drawn a hastily rendered happy face in magic marker. Underneath that is written the message, "Give us a smile." Like Rita Hayworth's picture that graced the side of the atom bomb they dropped on Bikini Atoll, there's something so pathetic, so vastly outmatched about this little happy face. It is like putting a garnish on annihilation.
机器球状、巨大、颜色是暗沉的医院绿，简直是50年代科幻小说里的死亡射线。我躺下抬头看。在我头顶正上方，视线平齐的位置，有人用马克笔匆匆画了一个笑脸。下面写着“给我们一个微笑”。就像那颗投在比基尼环礁的原子弹侧面画的丽塔·海华丝（Rita Hayworth）的照片一样，这个小笑脸显得非常可悲，非常无力。这就像是在毁灭上加了一道装饰。
Still, I never fail to smile. Even when I reach the point in the treatments when most of my hair has fallen out and my throat has been burnt to such an extent that I cannot swallow, I smile. They haven't stopped at the happy face either. Every time the lead door closes, latching with a booming clank, so too begins the music-- the same song every time, the same place in the same song every time.
尽管如此，我从未忘记微笑。即使到了化疗后期，大部分头发都掉光了，喉咙也被灼伤到无法吞咽的地步，我依然在微笑。他们也不止画了那个笑脸。每次铅门关闭，发出轰鸣的响声，音乐就会随之响起——每次都是同一首歌，每次都是同一段落。
The full horn section buildup of the chorus to the song, "You're Just Too Good to Be True." The plutonium drops down into the central cone. A warm wind starts to blow on my chest, indicating that I'm now getting the equivalent of a lifetime's worth of the recommended dose of gamma radiation. And I smile.
那首歌的合唱部分全号角部 buildup——“You're Just Too Good to Be True”。钚坠入中央锥体。一股暖风开始吹向我的胸膛，这意味着我正在接受相当于终身建议剂量 Gamma 射线的辐射。而我微笑着。
Two decades later, when cancer returned and killed him, the tumor was in that very same spot where the radiation had shot into him in that room in Princess Margaret Hospital. David had what's known as a post-radiation sarcoma.
二十年后，当癌症复发并夺走他的生命时，肿瘤就在当初在玛格丽特公主医院那个房间里辐射击中的同一个部位。大卫患的是所谓的放疗后肉瘤。
That's not what he's writing about in this essay, though. He's writing in this essay about how he remembered that period of his life, and specifically how numb he was whenever he thought about that period of his life, how he usually shrugged it off as no big deal, his long, first trial with cancer.
不过，他在这篇文章里写的不是这个。他在文章里写的是他如何回忆那段人生时期，特别是他对自己第一次抗癌那段长期的经历总是表现得很麻木，总是耸耸肩说那没什么大不了。
"It has only recently occurred to me," he wrote, "that perhaps I might stop glibly insisting that the cancer wasn't real and that the doctors popped me into an Easy Bake Oven where a 40-watt light bulb halted the metastasis in its tracks." David said that looking back, he felt completely detached from the fear or the relief that somebody might feel in remembering this kind of medical slow motion, near-death experience. And he described revisiting the old hospital years later, this place that was so important in his life, that saved his life, and just going back there and feeling nothing.
“我最近才意识到，”他写道，“也许我不该再轻率地坚持说癌症不是真的，医生只是把我塞进了一个简易烘焙烤箱，一个40瓦的灯泡就阻止了转移。”大卫说，回顾过去，他感到自己完全脱离了那种经历这种医疗慢镜头、濒死体验时一个人可能会感到的恐惧或宽慰。他描述了多年后重返旧医院的情景，那个在他生命中如此重要、救了他命的地方，但他回去后却感觉不到任何东西。
And then he launches into this passage, which is just intensely personal.
然后他引出了这段充满个人色彩的文字。
They say that times of crisis are the true test of one's character. I really wouldn't know, since my character took a powder that year, leaving in its stead a jewel-bright hardness. I was at my very cleverest that year, and airless, relentless kind of quippiness. Every time a complex human emotion threatened to break the surface of my consciousness, out would come a joke. Come on, give us a smile.
人们常说危机时期是检验一个人性格的真正试金石。我真不知道，因为那一年的性格离我而去，取而代之的是一种珠宝般的坚硬。那一年我最聪明，也是一种空洞、无情的俏皮。每当一种复杂的人类情感威胁到我的意识表面时，笑话就会脱口而出。来吧，给我们一个微笑。
I was Thanatosis' rodeo clown-- I still am-- and Eros' as well, as it turns out. Years later, in a tender embrace in bed with my first real boyfriend, he said my name. "Oh, David." I stopped, sat up and responded in my best Ed Wynn-- "Yes?" This kind of behavior, essentially, killed things between us.
我是塔纳托斯（死亡化身）的马戏团小丑——现在依然是——正如事实证明的那样，我也是爱神的小丑。多年后，在床上与我第一个真正男朋友的温柔拥抱中，他叫了我的名字。“哦，大卫。”我停下来，坐起身，用我最好的埃德·温（Ed Wynn）语气回应——“是吗？”这种行为，基本上，终结了我们之间的一切。
There was a period during the illness when I was at my very sickest, at 115 pounds, hovering in and out of consciousness. This month and a half was the one period in my life when I was not faking it, where I was not deflecting every emotion with repartee. That it would take millions of cancer cells lining up for their big Esther Williams finale in my lymphatic system for me to finally shut up is sobering-- or would be, were I to think about it, which of course I choose not to.
在我生病最重、体重只有115磅、徘徊在昏迷边缘的那段时间，是我人生中唯一没有伪装、没有用俏皮话阻挡每一份情感的时期。为了让我最终闭嘴，竟然需要数百万个癌细胞在我的淋巴系统中完成它们宏大的埃丝特·威廉斯（Esther Williams）式结局，这真是令人清醒——如果我要思考它的话，当然，我选择不去思考。
What remains of your past if you didn't allow yourself to feel it when it happened? If you don't have your experiences in the moment, if you gloss them over with jokes or zoom past them, you end up with curiously dispassionate memories, procedural and depopulated. It's as if a neutron bomb went off, and all you're left with are hospital corridors.
如果你在发生时不允许自己去感受，那你的过去还剩下什么？如果你不在当下经历体验，如果你用笑话掩盖它们或飞快掠过它们，你最终只会得到好奇而冷漠的记忆，程序化且空洞。就像中子弹爆炸后，你剩下的只有医院的走廊。
David returned to this thought, that cleverness can substitute for intimacy, in a few pieces of writing. It's in his book Half Empty. It came up memorably in the interview that David did with Terry Gross on Fresh Air about that book.
大卫在几篇作品中都回到了这个想法：机智可以代替亲密。这在他书《Half Empty》中也有体现，并在他与特里·格罗斯（Terry Gross）在《新鲜空气》（Fresh Air）节目中关于那本书的访谈中引人注目地提到了。
In your chapter about your therapist, you have a great description of yourself when describing your thoughts after telling the therapist that you're going to stop seeing him. And I'd like you to read that for us.
在你关于治疗师的那章里，你对自己做了一个很好的描述，谈到了在告诉治疗师你打算停止见他之后你的想法。我想请你读读那段。
Yes. This is when he-- I'm not talking about terminating. I seem to be avoiding the topic. And finally he stops me one day. I'm ranting about, I think, human rights in China or something like that. And he finally says, you know, look, we've got to talk about you terminating. This is a big thing.
好的。这是在他——我不是在谈论终止。我似乎在回避这个话题。终于有一天他阻止了我。我当时在长篇大论，我想是在谈论中国的人权或其他什么事。他终于说，你知道，听着，我们必须谈谈你的治疗终止。这是一件大事。
"Turning things around, I asked him what his feelings were about our ending things. 'I'm incredibly angry,' he responded fondly. 'How dare you. You should at least have to come and have coffee with me once a week.' I asked if he felt this way about most of his patients. 'Not really,' he responded. Sigh.
“转过话锋，我问他对我们结束治疗有什么感受。‘我非常生气，’他深情地回答。‘你怎么敢。你至少应该每周来和我喝次咖啡。’我问他是否对大多数病人都这样。‘并不是，’他回答。叹气。”
Should you happen to be possessed of a certain verbal acuity coupled with a relentless hair-trigger humor and surface cheer spackling over a chronic melancholia and loneliness, a grotesquely caricatured version of your deepest self which you trot out at the slightest provocation to endearing and glib comic effect, thus rendering you the kind of fellow who is beloved by all yet loved by none, all of it to distract, however, fleetingly from the cold and dead-faced truth that with each passing year you face the unavoidable certainty of a solitary future in which you will perish one day while vainly attempting the Heimlich maneuver on yourself over the back of a kitchen chair, then this confirmation that you have triumphed again and managed to gull yet another mark-- except this time it was the one person you'd hoped might be immune to your ever-creakier puddle shallow sideshow barker variation on adorable-- even though you'd been launching this campaign weekly with a single-minded concentration from day one. Well, it conjures up feelings that are best described as mixed, to say the least.
如果你拥有某种语言敏锐度，再加上无情的触机即发的幽默和掩盖慢性忧郁与孤独的表面欢快，把一个极其扭曲的自我夸张版本在最轻微的挑衅下表演出来以达到讨人喜欢且轻率的喜剧效果，从而使你成为那种被所有人喜爱但被任何人爱的人，所有这些都只是为了转移那冰冷而死气沉沉的真相——即你每年都面临着孤独未来的不可避免的确定性，你终有一天会在试图在厨房椅子背后对自己使用海姆立克急救法时独自死去——那么，这种确认你再次成功欺骗了又一个受害者——尽管这次是你希望免疫于你那越来越陈旧、肤浅的杂耍摊主式可爱表演的那个人——即使你从第一天起就每周以专注的精神发起这场运动。好吧，这引发的感受，至少可以说，只能用“复杂”来形容。
I just want to point out, since our listeners don't have a copy of your book in front of them, that most of that reading was one sentence, [LAUGHS] that one very well-balanced juggling act there. So I just want to ask you, did you consciously intend to keep that one sentence?
我想指出，既然我们的听众手边没有你的书，你刚才读的大部分是一句话，[笑]那是一次非常平衡的杂耍。所以我只是想问你，你是有意识地打算保留那一句话吗？
Yeah. Yeah, it felt-- well, I like a little ranty sandwich of a sentence or a lasagna of a sentence or a mille-feuille of a sentence, to be perfectly homosexual about the metaphor.
是的。是的，它感觉——好吧，我喜欢那种长篇大论的三明治句、千层饼句或千层酥句，用这种隐喻来表达同性恋倾向是完美的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I like things that build in that way with semicolons and em dashes and things like that.
我喜欢那种用分号、破折号等方式构建的东西。
Do you think of yourself as somebody who is the kind of fellow who is beloved by all yet loved by none?
你是否认为自己是那种被所有人喜爱但被任何人爱的人？
We're verging into territory that's a little too personal, so let me just say--
我们正在谈论一个有点太个人的领域，所以让我只说——
That's fine. OK.
没关系。好吧。
Yes, I do.
是的，我这么认为。
[LAUGHS] OK. We'll leave it there, I suppose.
[笑] 好吧。我想我们到此为止吧。
Yes, I guess so.
是的，我想也是。
If you're just tuning in, it's This American Life. Today we're remembering David Rakoff. When David was 23, after recovering from Hodgkin's lymphoma, all he wanted to do was move to New York City. He arrived in the city, got low-level jobs in the publishing industry-- first at a literary agency, then at a publisher. He wanted to write, but he didn't write. Instead, he was an assistant.
如果你刚收听，这里是《美国生活》。今天我们在怀念大卫·拉科夫。大卫23岁时，在康复了霍奇金淋巴瘤后，他唯一想做的事就是搬到纽约市。他来到这座城市，在出版业找了些底层工作——起初是在一家文学代理机构，后来在一家出版社。他想写作，但他没有写。相反，他是一名助理。
David later wrote about this for a show that we performed at a town hall in New York City for the fifth anniversary of our program. He said assistants like him did the same work as the professional secretaries but got paid a lot less with the thought that they were climbing the ladder to real publishing jobs. He said they were miserable. They hated the work. They resented the menial tasks they had to do. And they drank, a lot.
大卫后来在我们为《美国生活》节目五周年纪念而在纽约市政厅举办的演出中写到了这一点。他说像他这样的助理做着和专业秘书一样的工作，但报酬却低得多，因为他们以为自己在向真正的出版职位攀登。他说他们很痛苦。他们讨厌这份工作，怨恨他们必须做的卑微任务。而且他们经常喝酒，喝很多。
Our drunkenness was twofold. First, there was the liquor. But there was also the intoxication brought on by the self-aggrandizing conviction that we happy few, we cheery booze hounds, were the new incarnations of that most mythic bunch of souses, the Algonquin Round Table.
我们的酗酒是双重的。首先是烈酒，但还有一种陶醉感，来自于一种自我膨胀的信念：我们这些快乐的少数人，我们这些开心的酒鬼，是那些最传奇的醉鬼群体——阿尔冈昆圆桌会议（Algonquin Round Table）的转世。
This pipe dream sustained not just us but I suspect countless other tables of publishing menials all over town. So desperate were we to assume the mantle of Parker, Benchley, and their ilk that we weren't going to let some silly thing like a dearth of wit or the complete absence of a body of work on any of our parts deter us.
这个白日梦支撑的不只是我们，我怀疑城里无数其他出版社底层的桌子也是如此。我们如此绝望地想要披上帕克（Parker）、本奇利（Benchley）和他们同类人的外衣，以至于我们绝不会让才华匮乏或完全缺乏作品这种小事阻碍我们。
With enough $4 drinks sloshing through our veins, even the most dunderheaded schoolyard japery qualified as coruscating repartee. "What do you want?" a riposte might begin, "a medal or a chest to pin it on?" "Oh, touche!" we cried merrily as a clutched our martinis.
只要有几杯4美元的酒在血管里晃荡，即便是最笨拙的校园玩笑也足以被视为闪光的机智。“你想要什么？”一个回击可能会这样开始，“一枚奖章还是一个别奖章的胸部？”“哦，太妙了！”我们一边紧握马提尼一边快乐地喊道。
Paying the bill, we stumbled out into the street and back to our apartments, where we spent the rest of the night jealously reading the manuscripts of those who actually wrote and didn't just drink about it.
付了账单，我们跌跌撞撞地走上街头，回到公寓，在剩下的夜里嫉妒地读着那些真正写作、而不只是喝酒谈论写作的人的手稿。
This period in David's life pops up in other things that he wrote. For years, I've had this recording of him on my computer at work reading another essay on stage about his 20s. And now and then, we've actually considered it for this theme or that theme on the radio show. And it's one of those stories that never ended up on the air. I think mostly because the beginning of the essay is about the Broadway musical Rent. You remember Rent?
大卫人生中的这段时期也出现在他写的其他东西里。多年来，我电脑里一直存着他在台上阅读另一篇关于他20多岁的散文的录音。偶尔，我们也确实考虑过在广播节目中用它作为这个或那个主题。但这始终没能上节目。我想主要是因为散文开头是关于百老汇音乐剧《吉屋出租》（Rent）的。你记得《吉屋出租》吗？
[MUSIC - "SEASONS OF LOVE," RENT CAST]
[音乐 - 《吉屋出租》演员演唱 《Seasons of Love》]
OK, so Rent closed years ago, and so it just-- it was hard to put on the air, this piece, because it just seemed weird to pick a fight with a hit Broadway show that had closed and nobody was talking about any more anyway, you know? But it's this great piece of writing and one of my favorite recordings of David. A warning to our podcast and streaming audiences, on the radio, we beep a few words and actually eliminate a sentence or two that here on the internet we are not going to beep and that we're going to restore. So some of this might be the kind of thing you don't want your children to hear.
好的，所以《吉屋出租》几年前就下档了，所以就——很难把它放上节目，因为和一个已经下档、没人再谈论的百老汇热门剧斗气似乎很奇怪，你懂吗？但这篇散文写得非常好，也是我最喜欢的大卫录音之一。给我们的播客和流媒体听众提个醒，在广播里，我们对几个词进行了消音，甚至删掉了一两句话，而在这里在互联网上，我们不会消音，并会恢复它们。所以其中一些内容可能不适合你的孩子听。
There are 525,600 minutes in a year. I learned that from watching Rent. From watching Rent, I also learned that the best way to mark the passing of these 525,600 minutes would be to measure them out into something Jonathan Larson, the writer of the musical, called seasons of love. What does that even mean, seasons of love?
一年有525,600分钟。我是从看《吉屋出租》里学到的。从看《吉屋出租》中，我还学到衡量这525,600分钟流逝的最佳方式，是将它们划分成音乐剧作者乔纳森·拉尔森（Jonathan Larson）所说的“爱之季”。这到底是什么意思，爱之季？
In Rent, the characters live out their seasons of love in huge lofts. Some of them have AIDS, which is coincidentally also the name of a dreaded global pandemic that is still raging and has killed millions of people worldwide. In Rent, however, AIDS seems to be a disease that renders one cuter and cuter.
在《吉屋出租》里，角色们住在巨大的阁楼里生活在他们的“爱之季”中。他们中有些人患有艾滋病，这巧合地也是一种可怕的全球性大流行病的名称，这种流行病至今仍在肆虐，已经夺去了全球数百万人的生命。然而在《吉屋出租》里，艾滋病似乎是一种让人变得越来越可爱的疾病。
The characters are artists, creative types. They have tatterdemalion clothes. Some of them are homosexual, and the ones who aren't homosexual don't even seem to mind. They screen their calls. And when it is their parents, they roll their eyes. They hate their parents. They're never going back to Larchmont, no way. They will stay here living in their 2,000 square feet of picturesque poverty being sexually free and creative.
这些角色是艺术家、创作型人物。他们穿得破破烂烂。有些人是同性恋，而那些不是同性恋的人甚至似乎也不介意。他们筛选电话，当是父母打来时，他们翻白眼。他们讨厌父母。他们永远不会回到拉奇蒙特，没门。他们会待在这里，住在他们2000平方英尺的如画贫民窟里，保持性自由和创造力。
Here's some ways to broadcast creativity in a movie. Start plinking out a tune on a piano. Scratch a few notes on some music paper. Plink some more. Suddenly crash both hand down on the keyboard, then bring them quickly up to your head and grab the hair on your temples screaming, it won't work! Or sit at a typewriter, reading the page you've just written, realize that it's shit and tear it from the platen, and toss it behind you. Cut to waste paper basket overflowing with crumpled paper.
在电影中表现创造力的方法有几种。开始在钢琴上弹奏一段旋律。在乐谱上划几笔音符。再弹几下。突然双手重重拍在琴键上，然后迅速将手举起抱住太阳穴尖叫，它行不通！或者坐在打字机前，读着刚才写的那页纸，意识到那是垃圾，把它从滚筒上撕下来，扔到身后。切到装满废纸的垃圾桶。
Here's what they do in Rent to show that they are creative. Nothing-- they do nothing. They hang out. And hanging out can be marvelous. But hanging out does not make you an artist. A secondhand wardrobe does not make you an artist. Neither do a hair-trigger temper, melancholic nature, propensity for tears, hating your parents, nor even HIV-- I hate to say it-- none of these can make you an artist.
这是他们在《吉屋出租》里表现自己有创造力的方法。什么都没有——他们什么也不做。他们只是闲逛。闲逛确实可以很美妙。但闲逛并不能让你成为艺术家。二手衣橱不能让你成为艺术家。冲动的脾气、忧郁的本性、爱流泪的倾向、讨厌父母，甚至艾滋病——我不想这么说——这些都不能让你成为艺术家。
They can help. But just as being gay does not make one witty-- you can suck a mile of cock. It does not make you Oscar Wilde. Believe me. I know. I have tried. The only thing that makes you an artist is making art. And that takes the opposite of hanging out.
它们会有帮助。但正如成为同性恋并不能让你变得风趣——你可以口交一英里长。这并不能让你成为奥斯卡·王尔德（Oscar Wilde）。相信我，我知道。我试过。唯一能让你成为艺术家的就是创作艺术。而这需要与闲逛相反的东西。
So when they sing the anthem of the show-- that's a lie, really. Every song in the show is an anthem delivered with adolescent earnestness. It's like being trapped in the pages of a teenager's diary. So when they sing the title anthem of the show, "We're not gonna pay this year's rent" followed by kind of barked cheer of "rent, rent, rent, rent, rent, rent, rent," my only question is, well, why aren't you going to pay this year's rent?
所以当他们唱起节目的主题曲——那其实是个谎言。剧里的每一首歌都是带着青春期特有的真诚唱出的赞美诗。这就像被困在青少年的日记页里。所以当他们唱起剧名赞美诗“今年我们不付房租”时，后面跟着那种“租，租，租，租，租，租，租”的吠叫式欢呼，我唯一的问题是，好吧，为什么你们今年不付房租？
It seems that they're not going to pay this year's rent because rent is for losers and uncreative types. Rent is for suits. By contrast, they have the last bastion of artistic purity. They have not sold out, and yet their brilliance goes unacknowledged, so fuck you, yuppie scum!
似乎他们不付房租是因为房租是给失败者和没创造力的人的。房租是给穿西装的人的。相比之下，他们拥有艺术纯洁性的最后堡垒。他们没有出卖自己，然而他们的才华却得不到认可，所以去你的，雅痞人渣！
I know what it's like to feel angry and ignored. I lived in Brooklyn a long time ago about a block away from a prison. During the day, the neighborhood bustled with lawyers, judges, criminals, bail bondsman, private detectives. I lived on a block in a little two-story building that had once been a coach house in the 19th century. And the basement had a red dirt floor. On the ground floor below me was an office that did what exactly, resumes? I can't remember.
我知道那种感到愤怒和被忽视的感觉。很久以前我住在布鲁克林，离监狱大约一个街区。白天，街区里挤满了律师、法官、罪犯、保释担保人、私家侦探。我住在一个街区里一栋小小的两层楼里，那曾是19世纪的马车房。地下室是红土铺的地。我楼下的一楼是一个办公室，到底是干什么的？写简历的？我不记得了。
What I do remember is the man whose office it was. Raul was knee-buckingly handsome. If my life had been different like, I don't know, if I were like a hot girl with a driver's license, I could have put on a tube top and gone outside to wash my car in slow motion or something, but alas.
我记得的是那个办公室的男人。劳尔（Raul）帅得让人腿软。如果我的生活不同，比如，我如果是个有驾照的辣妹，我可能就穿上抹胸上衣，走到外面去慢动作洗车之类的，可惜啊。
Once during the day-- it must have been the weekend because I was at home-- I could hear Raul having sex in the office downstairs. I skittered around my apartment like a cockroach on a frying pan, trying not to make any noise while desperately looking for a knot hole in the crappy floorboards. Eventually, I just laid down flat against the tile of the kitchen floor, listening. Lying flat against the tile on my kitchen floor listening to someone else have sex is essentially in my 20s in a nutshell.
有一天白天——那一定是周末，因为我在家——我能听到劳尔在楼下办公室做爱。我在我的公寓里像煎锅上的蟑螂一样乱窜，试图不发出声音，同时拼命寻找破木地板上的节疤。最后，我只是平躺在厨房地板的瓷砖上听着。平躺在厨房瓷砖上听别人做爱，这就是我20多岁生活的缩影。
I was robbed in that neighborhood twice. And there were days when it hardly seemed worth it to live in a horrible part of town just so that I could go daily to a stupid, soul-crushing, low-paying job. Especially since as deeply as I yearned to be creative, for years and years I was too scared to even try, so I did nothing. But here's something that I did do-- I paid my fucking rent.
我在那个社区被抢劫过两次。有些日子，为了能够每天去一份愚蠢、扼杀灵魂、工资微薄的工作，而住在这种糟糕的地方似乎一点也不值得。尤其是我内心如此渴望成为创意人士，但多年来我太害怕尝试了，所以我什么也没做。但有一件事我做了——我付了该死的房租。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
David Rakoff. Coming up, how to give the winning toast at a wedding that you should not be at in the first place. More stories from David Rakoff in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
大卫·拉科夫。接下来，如何在本来就不该参加的婚礼上发表获奖祝酒词。更多来自大卫·拉科夫的故事，几分钟后在芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. It's the fifth anniversary of the death of our friend and contributor David Rakoff. And if you're just tuning in, we're replaying the program that we made five years ago remembering him, with stories that he did on our show plus a few other things.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天是我们的朋友和大卫·拉科夫逝世五周年纪念日。如果你刚收听，我们正在重播五年前为了纪念他而制作的节目，其中包含他在我们节目中所讲的故事以及其他一些内容。
This court is in session.
法庭开庭。
David's very first appearance on our program in 1996 was in a radio drama written in rhyming couplets by David Sedaris. It was about a courtroom where animals come to resolve conflicts. David Rakoff played a cat, a cat who was also the prosecuting attorney in the courtroom.
大卫1996年在我们节目中的第一次露面是在大卫·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）创作的一部押韵对联广播剧中。那是一个动物们解决冲突的法庭。大卫·拉科夫扮演一只猫，一只同时担任法庭检察官的猫。
Your honor, destruction's no small misdemeanor. The accused here is vicious. We should quarantine her. Now, I plan to prove beyond reasonable doubt that Kathleen the Spaniel engaged in a bout of senseless destruction.
法官大人，破坏不是小罪。被告心怀恶意，我们要把她隔离。现在，我打算毫无疑问地证明，凯瑟琳（Kathleen）这只西班牙猎犬参与了一场毫无意义的破坏。
Coincidentally, Rakoff's very last appearance on our program was also a radio drama in rhymed couplets, something that Rakoff wrote four years ago for the CBC radio show WireTap. In this thing, he played Dr. Seuss in a correspondence with Gregor Samsa, a man who found himself turning into a cockroach. This weird premise, if you heard this, led to some surprisingly affecting moments.
巧合的是，拉科夫在我们节目中的最后一次露面也是一部押韵对联的广播剧，那是拉科夫四年前为加拿大广播公司（CBC）的广播节目《WireTap》编写的。在那个节目里，他扮演苏斯博士（Dr. Seuss），与格雷戈尔·萨姆沙（Gregor Samsa）——一个发现自己变成了蟑螂的男人——通信。如果你听过这个奇怪的设定，它导致了一些令人意想不到的感人时刻。
I'm astonished at times when I think of the past of my thousands of rhymes of how life is so vast. I'm left, then, to wonder how anyone gleans a purpose or sense of what anything means. It's not ours for the knowing, its meaning abstruse. We'd both best be going. Your loving friend, Seuss.
当我想到过去那几千句韵律时，生命是如此广阔，我感到惊讶。我留下来，想知道任何人是如何从中获得某种目的或意义。这不是我们能知晓的，意义深奥。我们最好还是走吧。爱你的朋友，苏斯。
In fact, David's been doing lots of rhyming lately. A month before he died, he finished his last book, which is a story told entirely in rhymed couplets called Love, Dishonor, Marry, Die, Cherish, Perish-- A Novel by David Rakoff. Since last May when David performed a dance for the live show that we did, he's been saying that he didn't expect to live past August. And his goal was to finish the book by then. And he said a number of times that he really, really wanted to record the audiobook as well.
事实上，大卫最近一直在写韵文。在他去世前一个月，他完成了最后一本书，这是一个完全以押韵对联讲述的故事，名为《爱、羞辱、结婚、死亡、珍惜、毁灭——大卫·拉科夫小说》。自从去年五月大卫在我们做的现场演出中跳舞以来，他就一直说他没指望能活过八月。他的目标是在那时完成这本书。他曾多次表示，他真的、真的很想亲自录制有声书。
And so to get that done quickly enough, he came into the studio here at our show, and I recorded him. And there was one section that was just hard to listen to him read. He has one of his characters, Cliff, die of AIDS. And David was dying of cancer as he wrote this section. And in this section, he tries to capture some of what that experience is like.
为了尽快完成，他来到我们节目的演播室，我为他录音。有一个部分听他读起来特别难受。他让书中的一个角色克里夫（Cliff）死于艾滋病。而大卫在写这一段时正死于癌症。在这一节里，他试图捕捉那种体验。
What a difference a day makes. Now times that by 20. Clifford was hollow, a horn of unplenty. Tipping the scales at 115 at most, he was more bone than flesh now and less man then ghost.
一日之差，意义非凡。现在乘以20倍。克里夫很空虚，如同枯竭的号角。体重最多115磅，他现在与其说是人不如说是鬼，骨多肉少。
OK, a word about this recording. David was obviously weak, and the disease had spread to his lungs, which affected his breathing. In this part of the story, Cliff is coming to grips with the certainty that he is on a countdown to his end.
好的，关于这段录音说两句。大卫显然很虚弱，疾病已经扩散到他的肺部，这影响了他的呼吸。在故事的这一部分，克里夫正开始面对那种他已进入生命倒计时的确定性。
It was sadness that gripped him far more than the fear that if facing the truth he had maybe a year. When poetic phrases like "eyes look your last" become true, all you want is to stay, to hold fast. A new fierce attachment to all of this world now pierced him. It stabbed like a deity-hurled lightning bolt lancing him, sent from above, left him giddy and tearful. It felt like young love.
紧抓住他的不是恐惧而是悲伤，如果面对真相，他可能只剩一年了。当像“闭上你的双眼”这样的诗句变成真实时，你唯一想做的就是留下来，坚持住。一种对这个世界新的强烈依恋现在刺痛了他。它像神投下的闪电般刺穿了他，从天而降，让他眩晕而泪流满面。感觉就像年轻时的爱。
He'd thought of himself as uniquely proficient at seeing. But now that sense felt insufficient. He wanted to grab, to possess, to devour, to eat with his eyes, how he needed that power.
他曾认为自己在观察方面非常在行。但现在这种感觉变得不够了。他想抓、想拥有、想吞噬、想用眼睛去吃，他多么需要那种力量。
Just like a child whose big gun is a stick, Cliff was now harmless. He'd gotten too sick to take any action beyond rudimentary routines that had shrunk to the most elementary. Which pill to take now and where is your sweater? Did the Imodium make you feel better? Study your [BLEEP] to make sure you'd not bled. Make sure the Kleenex is next to the bed.
就像一个大枪只是根棍子的孩子，克里夫现在没有威胁了。他病得太重，无法进行超出常规日常的任何行动，那些 rutina 已经缩减到了最基础的。该吃哪种药了？毛衣在哪？易蒙停（Imodium）让你感觉好点了吗？检查你的粪便确保没有出血。确保床边有面巾纸。
Make sure. Be prepared. Plan out every endeavor. Like a scout on the stupidest camping trip ever. The facts were now harder, reality colder, his parasol no match for this falling boulder. And so the concern with the trivial issues, slippers nearby and the proximate tissues. He thought of those two things in life that don't vary well, thought only glancingly, more was too scary. Inevitable, why even bother to test it. He'd paid all his taxes, so that left, you guessed it.
确保。做好准备。规划每一项努力。就像最愚蠢的露营旅行中的童子军。事实现在更残酷，现实更冷漠，他的遮阳伞无法抵挡这滚落的巨石。因此，只能关心琐碎的问题，附近的拖鞋和手边的纸巾。他想到了生活中那两样不会改变的事物，只是匆匆瞥了一眼，想得太多太可怕。必然的，何必再去测试它。他已经交了所有税，所以剩下了，你猜到了。
I have to say I worry a little bit that the mix of stories that we've chosen for today's program gives a misimpression. It makes David seem like more of a loner than he really was. Yes, he was partly a loner, but he was partly just the opposite, with dozens of friends and people who loved him. And that last story was just way too sad to end our program with today, so one more story now. This last one is a favorite. It was first on the radio show in 2009. An expanded version appears in his new book. Here's the 2009 version.
我不得不说，我有点担心我们今天为节目选择的这些故事会给人留下误解。这让大卫看起来比他真实的自己更孤独。是的，他有一部分是孤独的，但他有一部分正好相反，有几十个朋友和爱他的人。而最后一个故事以结尾实在是太悲伤了，所以现在再讲一个故事。这最后一个是我的最爱。它最初于2009年在电台节目中播出。扩展版本出现在他的新书里。这是2009年的版本。
Nathan, at one of the outlying tables, his feet tangled up in the disk jockeys cables, surveyed the room as unseen as a ghost, while he mulled over what he might say for his toast. That the couple had asked him for this benediction seemed at odds with them parking him here by the kitchen.
内森（Nathan），坐在偏僻的桌子旁，双脚缠在DJ的线缆里，像幽灵一样观察着房间，一边沉思着他该为祝酒词说些什么。夫妇俩请他来做这个祝福，似乎与他们把他安置在厨房旁边不太搭调。
That he'd shown up at all was still a surprise. And not just to him, it was there in the eyes of the guests who had seen a mirage and drew near. And then covered their shock with a, "Nathan, you're here!" And then silence-- they'd nothing to say beyond that.
他居然出现了还是让大家很吃惊。不只是对他，那些看到海市蜃楼般靠近他的客人们，眼中都流露出惊诧。然后用一句“内森，你来了！”掩盖了他们的震惊。接着沉默——他们除了那个无话可说。
A few of the braver souls lingered to chat. They all knew it was neither a secret nor mystery that he and the couple had quite an odd history. Their bonds were a tangle of friendship and sex. Josh, his best pal once, and Patty, his ex.
几个勇敢的灵魂留下来聊天。他们都知道这不是秘密也不是谜，他和这对夫妇有一段相当奇怪的历史。他们的关系是友谊和性纠葛在一起的复杂网络。乔什（Josh），他曾经最好的朋友，和帕蒂（Patty），他的前任。
For a while he could barely go out in the city without being a punchline or object of pity. "Poor Nathan" had virtually become his new name. And so he showed up just to show he was game. Though, his invite was late, a forgotten addendum. For Nate, there could be no more clear referendum that he need but endure through this evening, and then he would likely not see Josh and Patty again.
有一段时间，他几乎无法出现在城里，而不成为笑柄或同情的对象。“可怜的内森”几乎成了他的新名字。所以他出现只是为了证明他能玩得起。尽管他的邀请函很晚才到，是一个被遗忘的附录。对内特（Nate）来说，没有比这更清楚的公投了：他只需要忍受完这个晚上，然后他很可能就再也见不到乔什和帕蒂了。
Josh's sister was speaking, a princess in peach. Nathan dug in his pocket to study his speech. He'd poured over Bartlett's for couplets to filch. He'd stayed up until 3:00, still came up with zilch. Except for instructions he'd underscored twice, just two words in length and those words were, "be nice."
乔什的妹妹正在发言，一个穿着桃色衣服的公主。内森掏出兜里的演讲稿。他翻遍了《巴特利特引语集》（Bartlett's）想借用些对联。他熬到凌晨3点，还是一无所获。除了他自己加粗标注两次的指令，只有两个字长，那两个字是，“要友善”。
Too often, he thought, our emotions betray us and reason departs once we're up on the dais. He'd witnessed uncomfortable moments where others had lost their way quickly, where sisters and brothers had gotten too prickly and peppered their babbling with stories of benders or lesbian dabbling or spot-on impressions of mothers-in-law, which true, Nathan thought, always garnered guffaws. But the price seemed too high with the laugh seldom cloaking hostility, masquerading as joking.
他心想，我们太容易被情绪出卖，一旦站在台上，理智就抛之脑后。他目睹过其他人迅速迷失方向的不适时刻，姐妹兄弟变得太尖锐，用酗酒、同性恋尝试或对婆婆的精准模仿来点缀他们的胡言乱语，内森心想，诚然，这些总是赢得哄堂大笑。但代价似乎太高了，因为笑声很少能掩盖那种伪装成玩笑的敌意。
No, he'd swallow his rage and he'd bank all his fire. He knew that in his case, the bar was set higher. Folks were just waiting for him to erupt. They'd be hungry for blood, even though they had supped. They'd want tears or some other unsightly reaction. And Nathan would not give them that satisfaction.
不，他会吞下愤怒，压制所有的怒火。他知道在自己的情况下，门槛设得更高。人们正等着他爆发。即使他们已经吃饱了，他们也会渴望血腥。他们会想要泪水或其他难看的反应。而内森不会给他们那种满足感。
Though, Patty a harlot and Josh was a lout. At least Nathan knew what he'd not talk about. I won't wish them divorce, that they wither and sicken, or tonight that they choke on their salmon or chicken. I won't mention that time when the cottage lost power in that storm on the Cape, and they left for an hour. And they thought it was just the cleverest ruse to pretend it took that long to switch out the fuse.
尽管帕蒂是个荡妇，乔什是个混蛋。至少内森知道他不会谈论什么。我不会祝愿他们离婚，祝愿他们枯萎生病，祝愿他们今晚会被鲑鱼或鸡肉噎死。我不会提起那次海角暴风雨中那栋小屋断电的事，他们离开了一小时。他们以为假装那是为了更换保险丝花费的时间是多么巧妙的诡计。
Or that time Josh advised me with so much insistence that I should grant Patty a little more distance, that the worst I could do was to hamper and crowd her, that if Patty felt stifled she'd just take a powder, that a plant needs its space, just as much as its water. And I shouldn't give Patty that ring that I bought her, which in retrospect only elicits a, gosh, I hardly deserved a friend like you, Josh.
或者是那次乔什坚持建议我应该给帕蒂更多空间，我能做的最糟的事就是阻碍和纠缠她，说如果帕蒂感到窒息，她就会离开，说植物需要空间就像需要水分一样。我不应该送给帕蒂我买给她的那枚戒指，回想起来这只会引出一句，天哪，我真不配拥有像你这样的朋友，乔什。
No, I won't spill those beans or make myself foolish to satisfy appetites venal and ghoulish. I will not be the blot on this hellish affair. And with that, Nathan pushed out and rose from his chair. And just by the tapping of knife against crystal, all eyes turned his way, like he'd fired off a pistol.
不，我不会揭开那些疮疤，也不会让自己变傻来满足那些贪婪和阴险的胃口。我不会成为这场地狱般联姻上的污点。说着，内森推开椅子站了起来。仅仅是刀叉敲击水晶杯的声音，所有的目光都转向他，就像他开了一枪一样。
[CLEARS THROAT] Joshua, Patricia, dear family and friends, a few words, if you will, before everything ends-- you've promised to honor to love and obey, we've quaffed our champagne and been cleansed by sorbet, all in endorsement of your hers and his-dom. So now let me add my two cents' worth of wisdom.
[清嗓子] 乔什、帕特丽夏（Patricia），亲爱的家人和朋友，在一切结束前，如果你们愿意，我想说几句话——你们承诺了尊重、爱与顺从，我们畅饮了香槟，被雪酪净化，这一切都是为了支持你们的“她的”和“他的”地位。所以，现在让我加上我两分钱的智慧。
I was racking my brains, sitting here at this table, until I remembered this suitable fable that gets at a truth, though it may well distort us. So here with the tale of the scorpion and tortoise. The scorpion was hamstrung, his tail all a-quiver. Just how would he manage to get 'cross the river? "Oh, the water's so deep," he observed with a sigh, which pricked at the ears of the tortoise nearby.
我坐在桌子旁绞尽脑汁，直到我想起这个合适的寓言，它触及了一个真相，尽管它可能很好地扭曲了我们。所以，讲一讲蝎子和乌龟的故事。蝎子步履蹒跚，尾巴震颤。他该如何才能过河？“哦，水太深了，”他叹息着观察道，这话刺痛了附近的乌龟。
"Well, why don't you swim," asked the slow-moving fellow, "unless you're afraid. I mean, what are you, yellow?" "It isn't a matter of fear or of whim," said the scorpion, "but that I don't know how to swim."
“好吧，你怎么不游过去，”那只慢吞吞的家伙问道，“除非你害怕。我是说，你怎么了，胆小鬼？”“这不是害怕或心血来潮的问题，”蝎子说，“而是我根本不会游泳。”
"Ah, forgive me. I didn't mean to be glib when I said that. I figured you were an amphibian." "No offense taken," the scorpion replied, "but how about you help me to reach the far side? You swim like a dream, and you have what I lack. What say you take me across on your back?"
“啊，原谅我。我刚才说得太轻率了。我还以为你是两栖动物呢。”“没冒犯，”蝎子回答，“但你能不能帮我到达彼岸？你游泳像做梦一样，你有我所缺乏的。你觉得带我游过河怎么样？”
"I'm really not sure that's the best thing to do," said the tortoise, "now that I see that it's you. You have a less than ideal reputation preceding. There's talk of your victims all poisoned and bleeding. You're the scorpion, and how can I say this, but, well, I just don't feel safe with you riding my shell."
“我真的不确定这是最好的事，”乌龟说，“现在我发现是你。你名声不佳，众所周知。到处都有关于你的受害者被毒死、流血的传闻。你是蝎子，我该怎么说呢，但，好吧，我只是觉得让你骑在我的壳上不安全。”
The scorpion replied, "What would killing you prove? We'd both drown. So tell me, how would that behoove me to basically die at my very own hand, when all I desire is to be on dry land?"
蝎子回答，“杀了你对我有什么好处？我们都会淹死的。所以告诉我，当我唯一的愿望就是站在干地上时，亲手杀死我自己有什么意义？”
The tortoise considered the scorpion's defense. When he gave it some thought, it made perfect sense. The niggling voice in his mind, he ignored, and he swam to the bank and called out, "Climb aboard." But just a few moments from when they set sail, the scorpion lashed out with his venomous tail. The tortoise too late understood that he'd blundered when he felt his flesh stabbed and his carapace sundered.
乌龟考虑了蝎子的辩解。当他仔细想想时，觉得很有道理。他忽略了脑子里那个唠叨的声音，他游向河岸喊道，“上来吧。”但就在他们起航后没多久，蝎子就用那根有毒的尾巴猛击。乌龟太晚才明白自己犯了大错，他感觉到肉被刺痛，甲壳被撕裂。
As he fought for his life, he said, "Tell me why you have done this? For now we will surely both die!" "I don't know," cried the scorpion. "You never should trust a creature like me, because poison I must. I'd claim some remorse or at least some compunction, but I just can't help it. My form is my function. You thought I'd behaved like my cousin the crab, but unlike him it is but my nature to stab."
在他为生命挣扎时，他说，“告诉我你为什么要这样做？因为现在我们肯定都会死！”“我不知道，”蝎子哭喊道，“你永远不该信任我这样的生物，因为我必须下毒。我本想要求一些悔恨，或至少一些愧疚，但我就是忍不住。我的形式就是我的功能。你以为我会像我的表亲螃蟹那样表现，但与他不同，刺人就是我的本性。”
The tortoise expired with one final quiver, and then both of them sank swallowed up by the river. The tortoise was wrong to ignore all his doubts, because in the end, friends, our natures will out.
乌龟在最后一次抽搐中死去，然后他们俩都沉入了河底，被河流吞没。乌龟忽略了所有疑虑是错误的，因为最后，朋友们，本性终会暴露。
Nathan paused, cleared his throat, took a sip of his drink. He needed these extra few seconds to think. The room had gone frosty. The tension was growing. Folks wondered precisely where Nathan was going. The prospect of skirting fiasco seemed dim, but what he said next surprised even him.
内森停顿了一下，清了清嗓子，喝了一口饮料。他需要这额外的几秒钟来思考。房间里变冷了。紧张气氛在增长。人们想知道内森到底要去哪里。回避彻底搞砸的前景似乎很渺茫，但他接下来所说的话连他自己都感到吃惊。
So what can we learn from their watery ends? Is there some lesson on how to be friends? I think what it means is that central to living a life that is good is a life that's forgiving. We are creatures of contact. Regardless of whether we kiss or we wound, still we must come together. Though it may spell destruction, we still ask for more, since it beats staying dry but so lonely on shore. So we make ourselves open while knowing full well it's essentially saying, please, come pierce my shell.
那么，我们能从他们的溺水结局中学会什么？有什么关于如何成为朋友的教训吗？我认为这意味着，过一种美好生活的核心在于学会原谅。我们是接触的生物。无论我们是接吻还是伤害，我们依然必须走到一起。尽管这可能意味着毁灭，我们依然要求更多，因为这总比干巴巴地待在岸上那么孤独要好。所以我们让自己敞开，尽管心里非常清楚这本质上是在说，请，来刺穿我的壳吧。
Silence doesn't paint the depth of quiet in that room. There was no clinking stemware toasting to the bride or groom. You could have heard a pedal as it landed on the floor. And in that stillness, Nathan turned and walked right out the door.
沉默无法描绘那个房间里安静的深度。没有高脚杯碰撞来为新娘或新郎祝酒。你可以听到一根针落在地板上的声音。在那寂静中，内森转身走出了门。
David Rakoff. When David decided to put that poem into his new book, he went back and he added a crucial fact-- a very, very, very important fact that he learned only after we broadcast the poem. So in the book, Nathan gives the toast and then he runs into a guy on the way out who informs him of the fact that David learned later-- this is from the book. The guy says, "That toast, if you give it again-- but you won't-- remember, Nate, turtles swim. Tortoises don't."
大卫·拉科夫。当大卫决定把那首诗放入他的新书时，他回去加了一个关键的事实——一个他在我们广播了这首诗后才知道的非常、非常、非常重要的事实。所以在书里，内森发表了祝酒词，然后在出去的路上遇到了一个人，那人告诉了他大卫后来才知道的事实——这是书里的内容。那个人说：“那个祝酒词，如果你再讲一遍——但你不会了——记住，内特，乌龟（Turtles）会游泳。陆龟（Tortoises）不会。”
[MUSIC - "WHAT'LL I DO?" BY NAT KING COLE]
[音乐 - 纳·京·高尔（Nat King Cole） 《What'll I Do?》]
Well, this episode of our show was produced by me and Brian Reed and Emily Condon and our senior producer back then Julie Snyder, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help today from BA Parker and Stowe Nelson.
好吧，这一集的节目是由我和布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）以及我们当时的资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）制作的，亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）也参与了制作。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。今天的制作协助来自BA帕克（BA Parker）和斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）。
David Rakoff's books and audiobooks-- Fraud, Don't Get Too Comfortable, Half Empty, and Love, Dishonor, Marry, Die, Cherish, Perish-- A Novel by David Rakoff are available online, wherever they sell such things. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
大卫·拉科夫的书籍和有声书——《欺诈》（Fraud）、《别太舒服》（Don't Get Too Comfortable）、《半空》（Half Empty）以及《爱、羞辱、结婚、死亡、珍惜、毁灭——大卫·拉科夫小说》都在网上有售。我们的网站是 thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。
When David Rakoff filled in as host of our show, one of the things that he had to do was read the credits, like this one.
当大卫·拉科夫代班主持我们的节目时，他必须要做的一件事就是读演职员表，就像这一段。
Funding for our show comes from Volkswagen of America and the new Touareg SUV, the Volkswagen that does what other Volkswagens don't-- kill you in a low-impact collision. More about the Touareg at vw.com. [LAUGHS] Please don't.
我们节目的资助来自大众汽车美国公司和新款途锐SUV，那是大众汽车——做其他大众汽车不做的事——在低速碰撞中让你丧命。（笑）请不要买。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That was kind of an ad-lib, that last part. Special thanks to our programs co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he gave this pep talk to the staff at our summer staff retreat-- not his most effective effort.
那最后一部分是即兴发挥。特别感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，他在我们的夏季员工静修会上给员工打气——那不是他最有效的努力。
Who will see their dreams fall away into the abyss and eventually succumb to the crashing sadness and meaninglessness of it all? We will!
谁会眼睁睁看着自己的梦想坠入深渊，最终屈服于那种毁灭性的悲伤和毫无意义？我们会！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "WHAT'LL I DO?" BY NAT KING COLE]
[音乐 - 纳·京·高尔（Nat King Cole） 《What'll I Do?》]